die ihnen das du mal letzten mal hier
das war schon toll
ein teil war das glaub ich hey leute was
glaubt willkommen bei neuen video und
zwar ich glaube also das ist jetzt so
eine dritte folge von seht ihr schon am
titel
ich habe davon auf jeden fall schon so
vor weiß ich nicht im halben jahr oder
so zwei ausgaben raus kann also so
beeindruckt man jede jung und kam
eigentlich ziemlich gut an deshalb gibt
es heute teil drei wünsche euch viel
spaß und was ich eigentlich noch so kurz
vorweg sagen sollte nicht das wieder
10.000 kommentare kommen von wegen ihrer
individualität blabla also es ist meine
meinung niemand muss da irgendwie
niemand muss dieser meinung folgen kein
plan wir fangen jetzt einfach an also
schild alle ein bisschen und heute
fangen mit punkt nummer eins an wie
immer natürlich und zwar es gibt
wirklich so mädchen da ist das so und
das ist eigentlich schlecht und zwar
weil ich damit diese mädchen kennt ihr
das ihr macht so ein witz so über die
meint dass gar nicht böse oder so oder
die haben irgendwas lustiges gemacht und
ihr sagte dass so erzählt es euren
freunden in deren anwesenheit und die
sendern direkt mega angepisst ich meine
damit so von wegen als mädchen oder wenn
man halt als mädchen so bei einem jungen
ganz cool ankommen möchte meiner meinung
nach dann sollte man auch wirklich über
sich selber lachen können und wenn man
immer nur sagt bin ich voll doof dass du
jetzt mal ein bisschen über mich gelacht
hast das mega scheiße oder ich zum
beispiel ich könnte auch mal wieder zum
friseur und wenn jetzt ein mädchen zu
bekommen würde und sagen würde deine
haare den scheiß aus dann würde ich das
auch so hin weil es stimmt eigentlich
ein bisschen ja heute kommt auch schon
zu punkt nummer zwei und zwar meine ich
damit so wenn man jetzt als mädchen
wirklich mein junge toll findet oder
also auch fast mit dem zusammen ist sage
ich mal was man dann wirklich auf keinen
fall machen sollte weil das geht ohne
scheiß jeden jungen offen sagt wenn man
wirklich als mädchen sein leben nur noch
nach dem des jungen aufbauen und sich
alles halt darum dreht und man gar nicht
so wenn man jetzt alle immer irgendwas
macht gar nicht mehr glücklich ist
sondern wirklich nur glücklich ist wenn
man irgendwas mit diesem jungen dann
fühlt man sich als junger direkt
übelst eingeengt und so also dieses
mädchen kommt da so rüber wie die größte
klippe und das ist eigentlich scheiße
würde ich jetzt zu sagen okay nächster
punkt es ist ja auch wirklich wichtig so
einem jungen zu zeigen dass man etwas
ganz besonderes ist so alt aber dabei
kommt es darauf an dass man ihm das so
zeigt dass man jetzt nicht angeberisch
rüberkommt also wenn man jetzt als
mädchen weg zu dem jungen geht und ihn
beeindrucken will und dann so ankommen
mit von wegen ja ich war da und da die
beste und da war ich die beste und
blabla das kommt eigentlich nie gut an
bei mir zumindest ich denke dann immer
so york führen gibt locker welche die
trotzdem besser drin also meiner meinung
nach kommt das nicht so gut an geht
einmal seit und sagt wenn ihr zum
beispiel das um das gut können ja dass
du das mache ich folge ansteigen mehr zu
sagen dem und dem und dem und dem bin
ich die beste wahl steht ihr keine
ahnung ich glaube ihr wisst was ich
meine wenn nicht dann könnte es keinen
kommentar schreiben ich antworte dann
bestimmt so eventuell ja doch ich lese
mir die kommentare eigentlich immer
durch kommen wir zum nächsten punkt und
das ist wirklich sehr sehr wichtig und
es ist auch wirklich sehr sehr gut und
zwar wenn jetzt als mädchen und jungen
ganz cool finde ich glaub ich sag das
ist schon zum zehnten mal obwohl das
grabmal der vierte punkt ist also wenn
hingegen ganz gut findet dann ist auch
sehr wichtig so die freunde von dem
jungen eigentlich auf eure seite zu
ziehen was heißt es eure seite ziehen
sodass sie hat auch den eindruck von
euch haben als wer die wirklich super
gut geeignet für diesen jungen und und
dass diese freundin dann wirklich zu dem
jungen hingehen und sagen hey die ist
voll geil claire dir so nach dem motto
wir das erreichen sind das halt die
freunde von dem jungen da hingehen und
sagen ja die ist cool keine ahnung seid
einfach lustig und verstellt euch nicht
und macht jede scheiße mit und dann
klappt das auch von ganz allein
eigentlich und da kommen etwa schon zum
letzten punkt glaubt ist es punkt 5 und
zwar das ist wirklich super super
wichtig und das kommt immer gut rüber
als junge mag man sowas eigentlich
ziemlich deutlich und zwar wenn jetzt
mit dem jungen sprecht in ihr wirklich
cool findet dann redet ihn so oft wie
möglich keit mit seinem namen an so also
nicht von wegen also ich bin jetzt ein
alex erwartet wir gehen das letzte mal
hier das war schon toll
chantal war das klug in so scheint jetzt
zu mir vor das fand ich voll blöd alex
ok meine stimme
also das meine ich damit nicht so
wirklich dass ihr also ab und zu halten
wenn ihr mit dem jungen rede sein
vorname erwähnt weil das mag jeder junge
eigentlich wenn du jetzt ein junger
bisher das video schaut auch wenn ich
gerade nicht wissen sollte warum und das
nicht magst dann schreib mir das in die
kommentare dann also ja ich hab's auch
im internet so bisschen gucken da mochte
wirklich jeder junge das bin halt ein
mädchen andauernd in vorne an sagt ich
weiß nicht wieso es ist es klingt auch
mega komisch aber das ist einfach so ja
heute an sonst würd ich sagen das war es
erstmal mit diesem video ich hoffe
natürlich jetzt hat euch gefallen falls
ja dann lasst mal den daumen nach oben
da mal gucken wie viele livestream sind
wenn ich mal ganz doll gespannt napster
und instagram als einmal können wir
gerne erfolg weil die rockerbande
unbedingt weiter mit dem letzten video
von also soweit man hier ein junger teil
2 zeigt dass auf jeden fall ab abonniere
ich vergessen wie der uns nächsten
sonntag niemand ist ja sozusagen
nächsten mittwoch wieder auf